ok back to back against Mateo let's see
what he does in the Russell limo
sticking it yeah i'm currently looking a
bit at some Sicilian line so it's a good
thing to try out it's very early c3
interesting you said good really i mean
a [ __ ] bishop a six-level play this you
should be 60 and that should be fine he
cannot castle of course Queen a fire but
I can play Quincy aids or queen bee 6 to
cover the bishop so what is the thing he
wants to might be three or what's the
thing oops just going to develop quickly
am sometimes you can play Knight h6 in
positions with the capture but I think
this is more logical it's more
aggressive now he cannot play let's see
for blunders eform and if he goes 595
I'm also quite happy there stuff tough
him to organize this so here in 95
and I mean just be six right takes
Bishop d3 looks absolutely tale of white
you come on after speed out I don't want
to lose this game with specific jutsu
time I mean after white has given me
this opening position really weird and
we can just castle and then place III
but he just gave me this position ok
Queen c6 I go 53 that looks great
it does not it doesn't take okay so see
eight or I can also play the Queen d7
that's also not a bad move form
sometimes like Queenie six or so I
wonder if it is castles long all of a
sudden
I mean like that does not want to
capture Hong in such a position but you
never know I might still happen yeah
yeah i was thinking Queenie six could be
good could be a good idea
I'll push him back first I don't know if
six is not bad either
yeah Queenie 60 is that wrong question
to cover this first
if he does cancel long what am I
actually playing we should be five and
then like a 5a for mating the movie 5
always have 95 that's not a problem and
now I do this I was interesting anyway
it has to play 92 now almost let F to
detune yep you know it's just like try
to get everything active how do I open
this up now to get to the king 95 now
looks good push threatens night before
and to Bishop this hanging do that looks
tough for white
don't see I move to be honest and so
this one 493 check on Bishop d3
you know so easily winning
put your mark long 93 chicken doesn't it
doesn't win immediately somehow going
out only one ok let's retin c4 yeah i
thought i would place a claim now will
be to looks like the best bank again
whatever then collegiate between fault
c4 9424 it's a bit of a show of stuff
but it that is really strong actually
yeah yeah it completely clang
we should be five check and night f4 and
that's a completely devastating also I
can win the Queen after Queen a one look
G to King takes Bishop Jake's but that's
not the that's not the cleanest way ok
this is actually better and now this one
the trends the full made on g2 what can
I do something better no but the trends
whoopty to checkmate let's see it
immediately 18 see an immediate late
okay then push the zip on white resign
and that's just to disastrous right now
I just played it like that turn that
move water I'm wrong in the opening just
castles I mean you see 3d for is normal
but you cancel first and then play it
and there is no particular reason to
rush it now I don't know you can hot
careful so not quite it has no upside
you know it just is an empress eyes move
on yeah this is an interesting one but i
can go these leagues this this i thought
should be great here you create that's
what I saw and that's a tattoo hard to
believe him what is completely
uncoordinated so looks fairly normal
yeah that that's not that's disastrous
yeah I should take care Anders estimated
that is actually still kind of
continuing yeah but some
this is fairly good young c4 is a big
threat which collapses the men would be
to collapses this is yes cat is a stress
okay look before us given by the comp
put that that's also good Ian I also
have this youporn now here is likely
won't lose on time but the black piece
was just completely a completely
dominated disposition vice president to
take on to know there are many wins here
ok guys thanks for watching